- [Narrator] Thank you to
Finimize for supporting PBS.
- Money is one of the oldest
aspects of human culture,
likely predating the written word.
It's woven into the fabric of
virtually all human activity,
like food, family, work,
religion, and celebration.
So it's not surprising that
there is a wide variety
of unique money customs around the world.
- Some of these may seem
odd or superstitious,
but for those who grow up with them,
they're just a part of life.
They can be ceremonial traditions,
symbols of prosperity or remembrance,
or even functional practices
that keep communities afloat.
- But they'll all make you realize
how important money is to humans,
not just economically,
but psychologically and socially as well.
- And maybe they'll encourage you
to look at your own weird
money traditions in a new way.
(bright music)
Our first stop is Africa,
Kenya to be specific,
where there is a long
tradition of coming together
to help community members who are in need.
"Harambee," a Swahili word
which means "everyone pulling together,"
is actually the official
motto of the country.
And yes, that is where the
meme-tastic gorilla got his name.
R.I.P.
- The word "harambee" can also refer
to an organized community event
that raises funds or help
for a specific cause.
If someone in the community
is facing a significant
problem or life event,
they can contact an elder
family member or tribal leader,
who will meet with other elders
to determine whether the
situation warrants a harambee.
If so, the word will go out
to friends, family, and coworkers,
who will come together
to donate money, time,
and emotional support
to the person in need.
Kind of like an in-person GoFundMe.
- Maybe you're not in financial trouble,
but you still find it
difficult to save up money
for important life goals.
If so, you might be interested
in the tradition of sou-sou
from West Africa and the Caribbean.
It's kind of like an informal
group savings account.
A number of people agree
to deposit a certain amount of money
into a treasury at regular intervals.
Once the total has reached a set goal,
the entirety is given to
one member of the sou-sou,
and a new recipient is chosen.
This cycle continues until
everyone has been paid out.
- Though they don't pay any interest
and you only get back what you put in,
sou-sous offer group accountability,
so they can be helpful to
people who have trouble saving
or don't have alternate access to a loan.
Similar arrangements exist
in Central and South American communities,
where they can be known as tandas,
cundinas, juntas, or pandeiros.
However, these arrangements
typically don't involve
a formal contract or any regulation,
so you have to be sure
that you're saving with
people you really trust.
- One of the biggest community
events in any culture
is the wedding,
so it's not surprising
that there are a lot of wedding
customs that involve cash.
In Nigerian weddings,
as the couple hits the dance floor,
guests circle around, showering
money over their heads.
In Filipino culture,
the women attendees line
up in front of the groom
to pin money on him,
while the men do the same for the bride.
And Italian brides
sometimes wear a satin bag
for guests to drop money in.
- In Japan, the bride and
groom receive cash gifts,
known as goshugi,
in a special envelope
called goshugi-bukuro,
which says how much and from whom.
But you can't just put
cash from your wallet
into the goshugi-bukuro.
The bills must be new and crisp.
- Most of these customs involve generosity
within a family or tight-knit community,
but many cultural traditions
look to expand that to charity.
One of the five pillars of Islam is zakat,
which means to purify,
and it's essentially a call
to donate money to the needy.
How much and how often can differ,
but it's usually around
2.5% of one's total wealth.
- In most Muslim countries,
zakat is voluntary and up to the donor
to decide who the recipient should be.
But in others, like Pakistan,
Libya, and Malaysia,
zakat is mandatory and collected
by state representatives,
essentially like a tax.
It functions not just
to help those in need,
but to reinforce the
spirituality of the giver.
By donating a small
percentage of your wealth,
you purify the rest of it.
- In Turkey, one way to fulfill zakat
is with a practice called askida
ekmek, or "hanging bread."
When you go to the bakery,
you can pay for an extra loaf,
which the vendor is supposed to set aside
for whoever can't afford to buy one.
The act of charity is
considered to be more powerful,
because the donor is anonymous.
- The Italians have a similar custom
known as caffe sospeso,
or "suspended coffee,"
which originated in the
working-class cafes of Naples.
If someone had a good day,
they can pay it forward
with an anonymous free
coffee to an unknown person.
You may have seen this practice pop up
in some American coffee shops.
- Superstition and money go
hand in hand in all cultures.
In China, cash given to children
during the Lunar New Year
shouldn't contain the number four,
as it sounds a lot like "death" in Chinese
and is, therefore, considered unlucky.
The Chinese also have a tradition
of burning fake money at funerals,
known as Joss paper,
so that the souls of the deceased
will have good fortune in the afterlife.
- In Turkey, it's said that
sleeping with gold in your hand
will bring you wealth and success.
In Greece, an empty wallet
is considered bad luck,
so be sure to put a bill or two inside
before giving one as a gift.
At Christmastime in England,
puddings are often baked
with a coin in the mixture,
bringing good fortune
to whoever gets the piece
with the coin in it.
And, of course, here in America,
if you see a penny on the
street and pick it up,
all day long, you'll have good luck.
- You know, the more we talk about
these different money customs,
the more similar they feel.
They all seem to relate to
family, community, charity,
or good fortune.
- Yeah, even though money
is a very functional tool,
you can see there's a lot of
human emotion tied up in it.
It's a symbol for prosperity and happiness
and also the glue
that holds families and
communities together.
- Oh, I've got one more
really weird money tradition for you.
Apparently in some Western countries,
they believe in a magical creature
who pays real money for,
get this, children's teeth.
- What?
- Not a joke.
When the child loses a tooth,
they put it under their
pillow while they're sleeping,
and then this elf or goblin or whatever
sneaks in, takes the tooth,
and leaves money behind.
- Ew, what does it do
with all those teeth?
- I don't know.
Maybe that's the currency in
Nightmare Land or something.
- Super creepy.
- Yeah
- [Both] And that's our "Two Cents."
- [Host] Thank you to
Finimize for supporting PBS.
Finimize is an app and newsletter
that helps you become a smarter investor
in 10 minutes per day,
delivering all the
insights and tools you need
to make smarter financial decisions.
- The newsletter summarizes
the financial news of the day
in just a few hundred words,
focusing on brevity and humor
to make the world of
finance more understandable.
You can spot under the radar opportunities
in tech, stocks, personal finance
that can help you expand your portfolio.
- For more information,
please go to the link in the description.
Before you go, we are
looking for your feedback.
Each year, PBS Digital Studios
conducts an audience survey,
and it helps us understand what you like
and what you want to see more of.
- You also get to help PBS pick new shows.
It only takes a few minutes,
but your feedback is
extremely valuable to us.
There is a link in the description.
Thanks in advance.
Thanks to our patrons
for keeping "Two Cents"
financially healthy.
Click the link in the description
to become a "Two Cents" patron.
(bright music)
- Do you have an interesting money custom
we may have missed?
Tell us about it in the comments.
(bright music)